creativity creativity according to
dictionary.com is the state or quality
of being creative Thanks
so if you're wondering how to become
more creative than you've probably
already searched how to be more creative
on YouTube and found a couple of videos
that didn't really satisfy your thirst
for knowledge or maybe there were some
videos that probably would have but they
were way too long and well you have more
important things to do anyways that's
what happened to me so I made this video
short and sweet
so here are three simple kind of weird
things you can do today that will
instantly boost your creativity number
one surround yourself with the color
blue a 2009 study from the University of
British Columbia found that participants
who surrounded themselves with the color
blue were more creative
while those surrounded by the color red
had better attention to detail so if you
want to do a better job of editing your
paper go to hell or some other red
colored place but if you want to be
creative find yourself a nice blue
colored room and get creating number two
listen to classical music especially
Mozart while the classical music genre
might not be everyone's cup of tea
study after study has shown that people
who listen to classical music especially
Mozart have a higher capacity for
divergent thinking and better
problem-solving skills in other words
they are more creative it's also been
shown that students who sing or play a
musical instruments score an average of
51 points higher on SAT exams number
three go for a walk everyone knows
someone whose paces like a mad person
while they're thinking or trying to
solve a problem well science shows that
it actually helps you solve problems and
create new ideas and the weird thing is
it's non environmentally based which
means you don't have to go walking in
nature or something to get the benefit
you two can walk around the living room
like a mad person and reap the creative
benefits so that's it
do those three things and according to
science you'll be more creative but what
would happen if you did all of them at
once
would they cancel each other out or
would the benefit amplifying well I have
no idea this is totally bro science at
this point but theoretically this will
boost your creativity exponentially let
me know how it works for you thanks for
watching if you like this video hit that
like button if you're new here consider
subscribing if you chuckled or at least
exhaled somewhat forcefully out of your
nostrils at any point during this video
share it with a friend if nothing else
leave a comment and let me know if you
like this style of video or want me to
back to the usual stuff catching the
next video